Donald Trump is a billionaire I guess
and he is begging for money in a dark
room with terrible lighting looking as
dark orange as we have ever seen this
guy
Donald Trump on the eve of his
arraignment and arrest and surrender and
fingerprinting and mugshot
recorded a video
in a very dark room
where he is issuing another plea for
cash he says he needs you to contribute
now I have to say it's not really clear
what you're contributing to are you
contributing to Trump's campaign are you
contributing to Trump's legal defense
fund what is he asking you for money for
doing the darkest we have seen Trump
literally and figuratively if you're
doing well because all of the things
that I've done have brought you wealth
and prosperity or at least you're
extremely comfortable it would be really
great if you could contribute to our
campaign you know how to do it ah so
it's a campaign contribution he wants no
president of the history of our country
has been subjected to such vicious and
disgusting attacks really but they only
attacked me because I fight for you it's
very simple they can't buy me and they
can't control me and that scares them
beyond belief doesn't really make sense
when you look at the polling but okay
since the very beginning I've shunned
the globalist special interest owners
who have made a fortune off of
destroying our country instead our
presidential campaign has always been
funded by Grassroots Patriots like you
your contribution today will show the
left that nothing can destroy the
greatest political movement in history
yeah so there are people donating to
Trump we we looked at some of that
fundraising data and indeed Trump raised
a pretty penny after the indictment was
announced but isn't he a billionaire
like why why does Trump need to raise
money why does a multi-billionaire need
people's money it doesn't really make
sense unless you understand that Trump
sees his followers as Marx in an ongoing
con now the fact that Trump is raising
money off of this
doesn't necessarily mean that it's good
or bad for Trump as I've said before it
does seem that Trump's followers are
being energized by the indictment and
indeed the indictment might help Trump
in the 2024 Republican primary I don't
see how the indictment gets Trump even a
single vote in a general election the
very same chaotic surroundings that
followed Trump everywhere which hurt him
in 2020
are going to hurt him in 2024 and an
indictment is absolutely chaotic now
Trump is trying to fundraise off of this
there's a good nice concise CNBC article
Trump campaign uses newly restored
Facebook page to fundraise off of the
indictment they have the official
election defense fund with a thousand
dollar match which of course we never
know if it's real or if it's not the
copy was as follows the radical left the
enemy of the hard-working men and women
of this country have indicted me in a
disgusting Witch Hunt please make a
contribution of 47 or more by 11 59 pm
to help defend our movement from the
never-ending witch hunts during these
dark times and we'll send you your very
own I stand with President Trump t-shirt
for free which as we know that could
become a collectible item uh I I wish
I'd stocked up on the Trump Knives By
the way before he was indicted I'm sure
they've just skyrocketed in value so
realistically
uh the grift simply continues this has
been a grift for a very long time and
it's not going to stop when the with the
indictment it wouldn't it if Trump
somehow ended up in jail which is not
going to happen I think the grift would
continue from there and we are going to
be watching the next 48 hours very very
closely is there a gag order does the
fundraising continue to Trump's
protesters actually come out and seem
even remotely interested in defending
him or is it just a couple dozen people
at Mar-A-Lago all of it will be live on
our YouTube twitch and Facebook and it
is going to be quite a couple of days